now that just freaks me out cuz that's
my partner Alexa pano Vega reveals her
Dancing with the Stars pro partner Mark
Ballas is dealing with a bum knee ET
spoke with Alexa and hubby Carlos Friday
at Teen Vogue's young Hollywood party
the pair revealed things are getting
serious at Dancing with the Stars
everybody's getting sore I mean well
we're all sore but hurt mark every is it
like five times today in the middle of
our dance need to stop cuz his knee was
like throbbing now that just freaks me
out cuz that's my partner he's the one
guiding me but this couple leaves work
at work you guys practice together at
all don't absolutely no Alexis says the
show is changing her at home though it's
given me more confidence I feel like
before I was kind of like I don't know
not necessarily down on myself but I
didn't have the confidence that I have
now she's doing incredible incredibly
well and she's coming home and she feels
good about it so happy wife happy life
right
well said Carlos and a little PDA had
Alexa saying early turkey burger he
really thought